- Three, two, one, see ya.
Base jumping is already the most
dangerous sport in the world.
Ah!
Then you're also mixing that
with big mountain skiing.
You're combining full intensity sports
in an unforgiving environment.
The risk factor is definitely pretty high.
(upbeat music)
I am Matthias Giraud, aka Super Frenchie.
I'm a pro big mountain skier
and professional base jumper,
and I like to put those
two sports together.
Ski base jumping is
skiing off a massive cliff
that would be too big to
survive and land safely.
So you use a parachute.
I like to use my parachute
as a tool to ski things
that otherwise could not ski.
I've been ski base jumping for 10 years
and the last 10 years have been filled
with a lot of fun adventures.
I'm gonna ski between the rocks
and then jump into the event.
I ski base jumped off of the Eiger
and also the Matterhorn in Switzerland.
Heaven's Eleven in Telluride.
I outran an avalanche by ski base jumping
off a 600-foot cliff.
Woo hoo!
That was a pretty cool day.
Did you see that avalanche?
Woo!
Fear is an interesting thing.
Your instinct tells you,
"OK, stop right there,
"don't go any further,
"this is the end of the world right there,
"this thing is gonna kill you."
This is the moment when
you have to take over
and be, "No, I'm gonna
jump off this thing."
And then you come flying off this cliff,
things get even faster and gnarlier,
then the ground is coming straight at you,
it feels like it's gonna eat you then.
God!
Aha!
The moment you land, oh
man, I love that time.
Turn back, look at where you came from
and then realize that something
super cool just happened.
(laughs)
Oh fuck!
Big mountain skiing base
jumping is not forgiving,
I've definitely lost a lot
of friends over the years.
I've almost died myself several times.
You gotta be on it; you
gotta do the right thing
if you want to do it for a long time.
Oh, that was a terrifying jump.
That was a close call, but, hey,
I'm alive, I'm not hurt, we did it.
We're all looking for happiness,
and some people find happiness
through balance and monotony
and routine in their life,
and for me, that's honestly
my worst nightmare.
I seek happiness through intensity.
I think that intensity can
bring the best out of people.
Aha!